تتصدر العاب الهاتف حجم الايرادات السنويه
في سوق الالعاب العالمي في عام 2022 حققت
ما يقرب من 92 مليار دولار اي نحو 50% من
ايرادات السوق ولعبه اونوروس كينجز
الصينيه جاءت على راس القائمه بمليارين
ومئتين مليون دولار اما العاب وحدات العاب
الفيديو مثل البلاي ستيشن
فقدرت ارادتها العالميه ب51 مليار دولار و
800 مليون دولار في السعوديه تهدف سافي
جروب لانشاء 250 شركه العاب داخل المملكه
وتوفير 39 الف فرصه عمل كما تخطط
الاستثمار 37 مليار وثمانمائه مليون دولار
في صناعه الالعاب خلال السنوات المقبله
يملك صندوق الاستثمارات السعوديه اسهمان
في كوبرا شركات الالعاب من ضمنها مليار
دولار وتسعمائه مليون دولار في شركه
المنتجه لك
ومليار و900 مليون دولار في المنتجه
لالعاب فيفا تهدف استراتيجيه السعوديه
ايضا الى انتاج اكثر من 30 لعبه في
استوديوهات محليه قادره على المنافسه
العالميه وان يسهم القطاع بنحو 13 مليار
و300 مليون دولار من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بحلول عام 2030